hey guys do you know what it's like to
get a tattoo
today we're gonna find out because i'm
gonna get my first ever
tattoo hey i also want one all right
smiley yeah now i'm gonna join you guys
grumpy all right i don't have to do this
alone let's do it yeah let's do it
[Music]
oh
it's going crazy
[Music]
um
[Music]
sure i'm sure
oh and there we go very happy size
placement
everything is good i'm blurring this out
i'm not going to show you guys
the real tattoo yet
i'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
it's terrible
[Music]
and grumpy what's it to you again no you
all have to wait and see here
what you're getting oh you have to wait
and see as well
don't be like that
this is it let's do this
all right again all right
here we go first touch ooh
i want to look but i want to look away
at the same time
then look down look down
oh that feels weird
my heart is racing
ah it's not too bad it's like a cat
scratch
now i can calm down
[Music]
it's painful huh i thought it's gonna be
a lot worse
[Music]
there's no tuning back now
so it's gonna take around three hours
two to three hours two to three
all right and then i got a tattoo
[Music]
yeah it's okay that part is not too bad
some parts of it is painful
[Music]
i'm just struggling to sit still i want
to move
you can't move
hey guys this is my tattoo artist show
and uh he's really doing a great job now
it's looking nice i didn't really work
here they just asked me to get here
so guys this is the tattoo artist for
for me today
it's unknown not gonna tell you guys his
name
um because it's his first day on the job
actually just kidding
oh second now he's been doing it for
for a lot of years
[Music]
has it there is france
[Music]
[Music]
not shaking anymore
[Music]
why do i baby
[Music]
i've been waiting actually for a very
long time since i was 18
on a tattoo design i was never happy
never get a tattoo when you're young
and when you're uncertain wait until you
know exactly what you want
and then you go for it
smiley are you crying smiley crying
[Music]
how's it going daniel yeah he did yeah
it's just that first few seconds you you
don't know what to expect and then
when it hits you're like okay this is
what it feels like and then you know
okay for the next few hours
head down and just wait until it's done
it's not that painful in the upper arm
other places probably worse
yeah it depends from from person to
person
but generally speaking this is one of
the least painful if you compare it it's
obviously still painful
okay but it also takes a while for your
body to adjust you know to get all the
endorphins and adrenaline and going
yeah that helps you out so the places
that hurt the most
those soft areas and areas close to the
bone
so generally speaking places where the
sun don't shine
delicate skin and then also bone places
are directly on the bone
it's also pretty pretty sensitive
depends on
person you know some people do have a
bit of a higher pain threshold
especially ladies
women have a way higher pain threshold
than guys yeah
you know some people do have a bit of a
higher pain threshold especially ladies
women have a way higher pain threshold
than guys yeah
that's interesting technically they
release more endorphins than what uh
what men do okay that's the chemical
advantage if i can call it that
yeah the start is painful but then you
get used to it and it's okay
and then some certain areas like that
the thick lines i'm having trouble
[Music]
so you guys wanted to know what's it
like getting a tattoo this is what it's
like
it's only a few times in your life where
you do life-changing things
this is one of them
the rest of your life looking at the
stats you're going to remember my ugly
ugly face no you didn't have a ugly face
[Music]
i think it's very silly for you young
guys listening to this video
never get a tattoo just because of
rebellion because
you want to spite your parents or
something like that that's what i'm
doing dhoni
no smiley he's joking he's joking
this chalk is still there
wow it's in that looks great
see when i use my left hand
just like uh hour left and then it's
done
[Music]
good you're done yeah thank you look at
it
beautiful awesome professional
what's it like grumpy burning it's cool
it's all the fine detail work now
[Music]
what will you tell someone smiley if
they ask you what is it like to get at
the 2 what will you tell him
painful
feels like a million different unicorns
licking your skin
why would you have a uniform
it's almost done
done yo nice nice
hey you're done yeah
it looks nice yeah almost done almost
it's good yeah it's professional yeah
what do you think
i like it it's pretty good yeah so do
you guys know what to do now
because i heard that the the most
important part is actually now how to
take care of it in the next couple of
weeks right okay
very very important so basically what we
do is we're going to use a derma skin
it's a second skin
it covers the skin keeps all the
bacteria out it keeps all the
hairs peta's dust particles all of that
out yeah
so the initial healing phases are
over and then we're going to take it off
you're going to wash it
with antibacterial soap and then you're
going to start moisturizing it
just to get all the dead skin off okay
basically going to keep it closed for
four days
take it off wash it nicely and start
moisturizing
okay yeah any specific creams
generally speaking in my opinion i
prefer using anything with vitamin a
vitamin d
okay a lot of the tattoo ointments that
are being developed are very good
um it's got essential oils it's got all
sorts of things that actually aid the
healing
um alternatively things like e45 works
really well
they use that for psoriasis for eczema
all those different skin conditions
so it does aid the tattoo very well in
healing it's not
anything oily i wouldn't suggest
anything oily or too thick
okay they've got some stuff here that we
can buy now as well we can go and check
out
you're bleeding yeah it's painful
[Music]
wash it off nicely take some photos and
wrap you up okay
great stuff you can go have a look
[Music]
i got a tattoo today it's only sinking
in now
and when it's done it's gonna burn
slightly but it's
slightly it's a quick burn do you
apologize
oh not yet i was like
ah now there it goes
yeah and you get a lifetime guarantee
laminated
[Music]
thank you that's it guys we got our
tattoos show it show it show it show it
you guys need to vote
which one do you like the most mine
grumpies what do you like smiling
let us know we'll see you guys in the
next video
cheers